la star montante du septième art
le nouveau coeur Douglas
le nouveau j'en garde dans le nouveau
Victor Lanoux le nouveau bouli
et cette personne j'ai bien sûr Raymond
on lui aurait proposé un autre un rôle
il a reçu un Sénart comme classe qui
s'appelle le camionneur alors non non
vous allez voir parce que hier on a
récupéré les offres de l'émission et
vous allez voir il en a dit un petit peu
plus à ses petits camarades sur le site
parce que j'ai quelque chose qui
pourrait se mettre en place et il y a
peut-être un projet un peu de
audiovisuel cinéma télé
j'ai reçu un scénario
sur la tête de mes enfants
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
comment tu t'appelles dans le film je
sais pas encore par exemple
ton personnage
est connu et le Real est connu et les
acteurs qui sont
mais c'est sûr
tu sais qu'on est en train de tourner
une nouvelle grande rassera
possible arrête non
non non non non non
le le réalisateur tu le connais
même toi tu les connais tu vas me le
dire dans l'oreille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
justement tu me connais la dernière fois
[Rires]
le réalisateur mais non
[Applaudissements]
j'étais acteur bordel ils vont mal le
prendre et t'inquiète pas c'est des
voyous les mecs t'inquiète pas c'est des
amis à toi mais c'est des voyous quoi
dis-moi mon frère
mon frère mon frère tu sais que tu es
mon frère et que je t'aime de et que tu
es voilà tu sais que on se dit tout tous
les deux c'est pas la question mon chat
me qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire de scénario qui a été envoyé à
Raymond pour qui joue un rôle dans un
film avec toi
[Musique]
très bien d'accord donc je suis dans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y a Raymond tu veux vraiment qui joue
dans la montagne les gars
on aimerait vraiment que lui et Sandy
alors Sandy c'est mon ami mon ami mon
frérot que j'embrasse fort qui va qui
écrit le film
et ah c'est pas pour nikoumouk
avec le dîner qu'on a fait l'autre soir
tout ensemble si tu veux tous ensemble
si tu te rappelles quand tu es parti
avant parce que ton fils était fatigué
on a on a fini par dire que on aimerait
bien avoir Raymond et Sandy comme ils
ont conduit beaucoup de voitures quand
il était plus jeune
c'est bon
bah très bien comme mon frère je t'aime
fort je te vois demain je viens demain
il vient demain sur le plateau mon frère
à demain
je suis rassuré tu vois je suis bien
producteur du film je ne savais même pas
ah oui non mais voilà donc il est
magnifique je te rappelle quand on avait
dit la dernière fois je t'ai déjà parti
moi je t'ai déjà parti non mais c'est
incroyable mais c'est énorme parce que
attention le film est énorme hein
moi je parle d'un autre film s'il y a
pas la voyante j'en parle pas moi c'est
dans nikoumouk bah ouais ouais
bien sûr franchement le mec
maintenant que je viens d'apprendre en
plus ce sont vraiment c'est pas mes amis
c'est mes frères
voilà ça donc on y sera les gars
j'aimerais te tester un petit peu
comme tu vas il va avoir une voix off
qui va te donner des intentions tu as
des accessoires ici
tu vas devoir jouer les intentions
de l'actrice internationale elle va
pouvoir dire il peut intervenir quand
elle veut d'accord vraiment toi
vraiment tout en impro vas-y allez c'est
important c'est pour moi la c'est le
producteur qui parle
[Applaudissements]
alors vas-y bordel la voix off il y a
toujours la voix off je fais tout seul
attends t'inquiète pas il y a une prof
qui va te donner des indications vous
avez toujours la voix ou pas
d'accord très bien l'action se passe
dans les années 90
Raymond un jeune loubard de Rungis qui
n'a pas peur de la castagne est accoudé
au comptoir avec son pote Cyril un
vendeur de mocassins qui n'est jamais
contre une petite baston je suis là tous
les deux s'interrogent de leur présence
dans cette soirée et le cruellement de
nénette
[Musique]
pour éviter l'ennui les délibards
décident de se rendre sur la piste et de
faire leur meilleur pâtes
[Applaudissements]
Raymond se rapproche de plus en plus de
Cyril et le fixe dans les yeux
amoureusement comme s'il venait de voir
un camion tout neuf
c'est une vraie romance qui s'installe
entre eux
[Applaudissements]
pendant qu'il danse l'agent de sécurité
du Night Club fait son entrée sur la
piste de danse pour demander à nos deux
compères si tout se passe bien
[Applaudissements]
voilà la Bible ça va voilà la gym
j'espère que tout se passe bien pour
vous les frères
[Rires]
dans la boîte Cyril aperçoit une jolie
blonde maquillée comme un carré d'as
elle a l'air triste parce qu'elle a été
coupée au montage de Batman versus les
tuches
Cyril Laborde pendant que Raymond
enflamme le dancefloor
[Applaudissements]
a
voyons que Béatrice n'a pas de morale
Raymond s'approche d'elle pour la faire
sourire avec sa meilleure blague père
d'autoroute celle du tire mon doigt
[Applaudissements]
pour moi
mais voyons de loubard autour d'une
femme l'agent de sécurité vient les voir
pour les mettre en garde
il arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
battez-vous laissez-les tranquille
au même moment Delphine une jolie brune
à l'allure énoncée et au sourire à pas
piqué des hannetons fait son entrée sur
la piste de danse
[Applaudissements]
mon Dieu que pour elle laissons ainsi
Béatrice seul dans son chagrin ce qu'ils
ne vont pas se gêner à lui dire
qu'on attend cette soirée
moi je vais te donner des intentions
à chaque fois je vais donner des phrases
par exemple là tu vas tu vas devoir dire
je ne pourrais pas être tribunal à 14h30
c'est ta phrase je ne pourrais pas être
au tribunal à 14h30
je le dis à qui à quelqu'un
un juge je peux te faire
monsieur Abou
retour
de tribunal
c'est mort 14h30 je pourrai pas être là
demain pas mal non non
je ne pourrai pas être au tribunal à
14h30 il faut tous les indications on la
refait non mais s'il vous plaît
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis à bout
que vous soyez au tribunal de ma 14h30
je ne pourrai pas être là demain à 14h30
mais où ça
il a
va
j'ai compris
écoutez-moi bien
je vous attends que vous le vouliez ou
non à 14h30 demain au tribunal je ne
pourrai pas être là demain à 14h30 au
tribunal
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
à 14h30 au tribunal
je pourrais pas être là demain à 14h
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là tu l'as fait triste tu es vraiment
très triste
malheureusement monsieur Abou
on vous attend demain au tribunal à
14h30
je pourrais pas être demain au tribunal
à demain pourquoi pas demain après
demain
je peux pas
vous savez la vie spa c'est pas blanc
c'est pas noir
après demain attends il faut que tu me
fasses arrogant arrogant un peu il est
bon hein
on vous attend demain au tribunal
à 14h30 précise
je serai demain au tribunal à 14h30
précise et on passe au petit ton là avec
nous on descend des deux étages monsieur
ah bon c'est votre souhait je serai là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
monsieur
nous vous attendons demain à 14h30 je
serai là à 14h30
[Rires]
vous êtes donc coupable j'ai jamais
parlé de tribunal dans ma phrase oh
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ]